Bill Emerson, the CEO of Quicken Loans, is a strong believer in an "open door" policy,...
...which means his door is always open to any of his staff.
He is also against hierarchical notions like boss and worker and prefers the title "team leaders".
Effective communication is a top priority in his company, and in this way, he personalizes communication.
He arranges weekly face-to-face meetings with his staff where questions can be asked...
...and any concerns and opinions are expressed because the daily personal interactions are most important.
Leaders do not spend their days locked up in their offices...
...but spend a large part of the day on the "shop floor"...
...and are in touch with team members, working alongside them.
In this way, leaders are more reachable and thus help to improve morale.
The staff comment that they enjoy the general informality.
They receive important business messages and understand the direction the company is headed.
They also don't feel awkward or afraid to ask about anything.